okay today I'm going to talk to you
about ionic equations so all an ionic
equation is is it's an equation that's
only interested in what's happening with
the ions so what we're going to do is
I'm going to show you an example of how
to write an ionic equation from this
simple equation here so the first thing
that we need to do is we need to
establish which out of all of these
substances are going to form ions when
in solution so which ones involved ionic
bonding and so sodium hydroxide we have
it's going to form ionic bonds here so
we're gonna have sodium and hydroxide we
can have hydrogen ions and sulfate ions
we're going to have sodium ions and
sulfate ions but here because water this
is a covalent molecule so as a result
this one does not form ions in solution
okay so now we've established in
solution which ions are going to form so
what we now need to do is write out all
of the different ions within this
equation so to begin with it says here
we've got two when this in solution this
is going to break down into two sodium
ions and two hydroxide ions so sodium
let's think use our periodic table
sodium is in Group one of the periodic
table that means it has one electron in
its outer shell so to lose an elector
form an ion it leads to lose one
electron therefore sodium has a positive
charge of one plus charge so to begin
with we're showing this as two and a
plus and I'm just showing aq to show
that's in aqueous solution okay next up
let's have a look so this is going to
break down into two hydroxide ions
hydroxide ion is just one you're going
to have to remember oh h- is a hydroxide
ion okay next up we've got our h is now
in solution because we've got two here
this means we're gonna have but when
this dissolves we're gonna have two
hydrogen ions so hydrogen
forms h+ ions and next up we've got our
sulfate right here so again sulfate is
just one of those ions that you need to
learn off by heart so4 2 minus is the
charge and finally let's do the
substances on this side of the equation
so my products so again I'm gonna have
to na plus because it shows I've got two
of these sodium's and so in solution
they're going to have two of those also
just got one so4 which has a 2 minus
charge now the final part because my
water is a covalent compound and not
ionic this does not break down into ions
in solution so as a result oops I forgot
to write my a key for that on that as a
result it's just 2 h2o still because
because this is covalent molecule it
does not break down into ions in
solution like the others
so my state symbol for this one it's
just L to show that it's a liquid rather
than aqueous in solution so what I've
now got is all of my different ions that
are involved in this equation my next
step is to go through and cancel out the
islands that are the same on both sides
of the equation so if I have a look at
this 2 na plus I can see I've also got
to na plus on this side so my sodium
hasn't changed so as a result I'm gonna
get rid of both of those I'm not
interested in those let's have a look
now where to Oh H - that's not doesn't
appear on that side so that has changed
similarly my two h+ i can't see that on
this side so that has changed as well my
sulfate ion I can see I've got sulfate
on both sides of the equation so I'm
going to get rid of those as well and
finally I don't have water on this side
so something has changed so that shows
me what I've got left this is just my
completed equation all I need to do now
is I take what I've got left so there's
my 2 Oh H -
plus my two h+ and I've formed this here
- h2o which is a liquid so I've canceled
out the the ions that are same on both
sides of the equation and this is what
I'm left with this is the ionic equation
for this here and this particular one is
an example of a neutralization reaction
because I have a hydroxide adding two
high hydrogen ions to form water and as
you can see it is balanced because I've
got four hydrogen's on this side four
hydrogens this side I've got two oxygens
this side and I've got two oxygens this
side thank you very much